well it's been an incredible week in the
world of Donald Trump lurid allegations
and one of the most heated presidential
press conferences in history and he's
not even in the White House yet well the
man with the ear of the president-elect
Nigel Faraj joins me now in the studio
and hello
good to see good morning I'm not sure
there's ever been a president entering
the White House under such a cloud of
controversy you've spent more time with
him than any other UK politician since
he won that election how was he going to
turn it around how he's not and then
please if anyone thinks that he's going
to become a president like the previous
44 the heat just forget about it he's it
you need isn't going to be like that he
will go on tweeting he will go on saying
what he thinks he will go on generally
ignoring the media and rather than doing
press conferences he'll do a YouTube
clip or whatever it is though this is
going to be completely and utterly
different what matters frankly isn't
what the commentary I think what matters
is what the American people think but
then the American people he actually got
the lowest approval ratings of a
president-elect since Poland began with
a fantastic 37 percent what a great
place to start
absolutely ideal maybe you start with
relatively low expectations but then
show people that you can bring money
back to America you can bring jobs back
to America and control the border with
Mexico if he can do those things what
you'll see is his popularity ratings go
through the roof there's all of course
that famous dataview by the gold
elevator yeah in Trump Towers when was
the last time you spoke to him oh I'm
just trying to think just for Christmas
mm-hmm just before Christmas but
obviously we're out there this week it's
going to be very exciting I mean look I
know I know that people look at this guy
and from this side of the Atlantic you
know all they've seen is controversy
negativity I mean all I would say is
this he has appointed some absolutely
first-class people to big positions
these are the people running America
they are self-made billionaires by our
very successful generals in the US Army
they're not part of sort of typical
career policy I think not typical career
politicians some of those like close to
Russia run their well business wise what
I mean one in particular has been I mean
obviously the relationship with Russia
he's dominating everything at the moment
and the you know there's even talk of
perhaps a recce Vick summit rather as
Reagan did with Gorbachev all those
years ago I think the important thing is
this I mean there is nothing absolutely
nothing to be lost in him sitting down
and talking with that Emir Putin and the
idea that somehow he's going to appease
Putin or give in to Putin or hand over
our security secrets to Putin frankly is
nonsense at the moment at the moment as
it complete standoff between all of us
in the West and Russia
we're back to the Cold War if a
conversation could ease those tensions
surely that makes sense but doesn't that
worry you I mean Russia has bombed
hospitals in Syria they've hacked a
democratic election they've invaded a
neighboring state isn't it worrying that
Donald Trump is appearing to be quite
consummatory well I think that the point
about the invasion of the Crimea the
takeover of the Crimea is that this is a
conflict that we provoked right from the
start our expansionist attitude towards
the Ukraine the European Union NATO
wanted to take that country and that is
what sparked all of this we need a
different approach towards Russia one
that is not in any way going to give in
or appease them but one that says
perhaps poking the Russian bear with a
stick isn't that intelligent now Keynes
talk to you about brexit you clearly
think that Donald Trump is going to be a
good thing for the UK and for trade
relationships but I just want to have a
look at what the man that we can be
negotiating with his said so this is
Wilbur off his Commerce Secretary
talking about brexit and the
opportunities for other countries to
take advantage he said I think this is a
god-given opportunity I mean that
doesn't sound that friendly to the UK to
me really well you know actually there
is something about free trade and a
reduction of barriers and an increase in
investment that can be good for both
sides that's the point and we are in
this situation where we have potentially
a very protracted renegotiation with the
European Union and frankly given the
amount of time the Prime Minister's
taking to even declare article 50 I
think it will be quite protracted what
we have got here is a fantastic
opportunity really to strengthen our
negotiating hand in Brussels I am
absolutely certain knowing not just
Trump but know many of the Trump team
I'm absolutely certain they want to show
the outside world that they're not
protectionist they're worried about
trade deals they worried about trade but
places like China where state subsidy is
closing down steel production in America
we you know we could even argue South
Wales come to that but when it comes to
countries that are equivalent that
they're open to doing business I suspect
that within the first few months of a
trump presidency there will be a big
statement from Wilbur Ross or someone
like that saying we want to do this and
by the way you know we're not
bureaucrats we're not people who've
lived on the public sector Percel of our
lives this won't take two years or five
years or ten years we want to get this
done in three months and then then it's
going to be up to the British government
to see how they respond to it that was
very interesting this week Theresa May
was with the premier of New Zealand who
said we want to start trade talks for
the UK Theresa May said yes good idea
we'll do it when the time is right
meaning when Mr Younker says we're
allowed to talk in New Zealand now at
the same time the UK did more trade with
the EU in two days last year than they
did with the New Zealand over there yeah
and that is the argument that says we
should be insular Little Britain we
should purely focus on Europe and forget
about the rest of the world much of
which is expanding far more rapidly the
whole point about brexit brexit nobody
on the brexit side made an insular
argument we made the argument with
freeing ourselves to re-engage with the
rest of the world now here's the problem
if the European Union tell us we can't
do that until the two-year process is
out of the way you suddenly start to ask
yourself is it really worth coming
through two years of renegotiation and
losing all of these opportunities so I
think we're going to have to start
standing up for ourselves in the
council's of Brussels so what are you
hoping from Tories amazed Breck six
speech next week I mean it sounds like
all your dreams about to come true
yeah the customs union well she seemed
pretty tough with you last Sunday on
your first show I mean sort of strong
hints that we wouldn't stay part of the
single market and then the next day gave
a statement that appeared to contradict
it I'm quite certain that Theresa May
will do what
always does she will sound very
reassuring she will look to be very much
in control she will say all the right
things and people at me will say well it
sounds great but why is it taking so
long and when it comes to immigration in
particular which she is highlighting you
know this is coming from the person who
was Home Secretary failed completely I'm
yet to be convinced I have to say I'm
interested
just quickly finally about your roller
coaster yeah you fail to become an MP
and you fail to become the US ambassador
as well now you're a radio DJ hoax is it
coming crashing back down to reality or
below I'm doing what I want to do you
know I'm not leading a political party
it leaves me free to be a commentator I
can do radio I can write I can appear on
television I'm still then I'm seven MEP
you know I'll be there watching those
negotiations once article 50 has been
triggered I'm just freed from running a
political party and I'm very happy very
positive spin spit on that Nagaraj
thanks for being with us